okay chris
now with all the traffic and the people
you won't get home too early in the
morning but you're gonna be the first
male to walk through the door for the
new year so here's 20 keep it in your
wallet that's to bring us luck and good
fortune for the rest of the year got it
okay oh i love you
be safe
be careful
even though my resolution was coming to
pass it didn't matter when it came to
the cops oh
sorry folks well we're at capacity all
right we got over two million people in
there now capacity is times square
[Applause]
what what difference is four more people
gonna make we came all the way from bed
stop well you should have came earlier
now step back no no no no no no baby
if i wasn't or performing i swear
maybe we should just find a bar or
something watching on tv nah we seeing
this ball drop
i know what to do
right back
[Applause]
ain't nobody shooting boy come on i
heard some gunshots
while we were trying to get into times
square my dad was trying to get through
traffic come on people
my father had the key to the city but it
couldn't open gridlock
back home tanya was awake and drew had
glue on his face girl would you stop
while i hopping around and help me put
these bags in the window do you think
daddy's gonna make it home before
midnight i hope so
i got a crush on you
while tanya's heart was beating a mile a
minute my dad was driving at the same
rate of speed
that was i've got a crush on you by the
jets helping to bring in the new
and that job get out of the way
[Applause]
i never really believed in things like
new year's resolutions but for the first
time in my life i remember thinking that
dreams can't come true
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
six
[Applause]
five
[Applause]
four
three
two
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
kissing tasha on new year's eve was
amazing my only fear was that i was
going to turn into a pumpkin at midnight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
chris
so how did it go
great it was the best night of my life
did you have any problems no did anybody
get arrested no
detained no
search no
question
no it was perfect
damn i forgot the first guy in the house
supposed to have money in his pocket no
no no no baby i already took care of
that i made sure you were in the house
before midnight and before chris left i
gave him 20 to ensure that we would have
luck and good fortune for the rest of
the year just in case the black eyed
peas don't work so now if you would
kindly give me my twenty dollars back so
we could get this year started
[Music]
boy don't play with me give me my money
hey y'all sorry to bother you i let
myself in peaches needed me to come
through the door with some money in my
pocket since i was gonna be the first
man through the door after midnight so i
pickpocketed chris
anyway
i just wanted to give you back
your wallet
happy new year
he was supposed to have that money in
his pocket
and now we're gonna have bad luck for
the rest of the year
great
happy new year
[Music]
oh
[Music]